all right man you ready to do it ready
to rolls do it we were just saying
before for hitting record that it's a
tricky challenge to try to figure out
how to embrace the fact and enjoy the
fact that it's like 85 degrees out on
know better wouldn't know for November
February 5th yeah it's insane and at the
same time recognize the fact that it's
bananas yeah I mean trying to be present
to the moment at at the same time
recognized at the moment is kind of
[ __ ] up is is like a dynamic tension
so if you I'm trying to be in the moment
and not be too conscious of what's
causing this moment mm-hm and yet if you
don't if you it kind of feels like I
have my head in the sand if I'm doing
that so it's yeah it's it's a it's an
odd tension right and we're living it
most aspects of our lives
so maybe we can canvas exactly what is
going on that is contributing to this
assume somebody who's listening has only
the most rudimentary basic sense of
global climate change and and perhaps we
could do like a laundry list of what
exactly is going on and contributing to
this situation that we currently face so
humans in civilization we like to think
of as progress and and much of it has
led to incredible technological
revolutions it really has transformed
the way that we live that we relate to
each other but about 200 years ago when
the Industrial Revolution started we
found that there was this incredible
resource this energy in a liquid form
gasoline that basically is very very
condensed organic matter that from the
time of the dinosaurs has been sitting
there gaining more and more energy and
when you put it in a car or a factory it
runs things like a miracle incredible
right so it's pretty cool it runs nearly
everything that that we think of the
ships that are coming or
across from China bringing goods the
trains the buses the cars their homes
factories all run on fossil fuels the
reason they're called fossils is because
that's what they are exactly when you
burn them they produce carbon dioxide
and and we breathe out carbon dioxide so
people who are cynical or don't believe
in climate change up and say well this
has happened for four millennia we've
had changes in the climate and that's
true what's different now is that we're
causing the change in the climate which
is sits uncomfortably with people
especially people who have faith because
they think how could we insignificant
humans really be changing our climate
but we are really the most monumental
aspect is the pace of change when we've
had climate variations in the last
hundred thousand years they've happened
very slowly this is happening very
dramatically so the release of
greenhouse gases they're not just
they're not just carbon there are other
things like your refrigerator has freon
and other coolants that also actually
they do it much much quicker they're
about seventy to a hundred times more
potent than co2 so all these gases are
going into the atmosphere and they trap
heat so when you think about the rays of
the Sun coming to us right now nice and
warm in this room when it bounces back
up what used to happen is it bounced
back up into space and a lot of that
heat would dissipate into space now what
happens because these gases trap the
heat is that it's getting warmer and
warmer and it's leading not just to
global warming which it used to be
called but climate change a lot of
variability you see the Hurricanes that
we had hurricane Emma you see what
happened from Dallas to Puerto Rico but
also leads to a lot colder weather so
weather variability is going to become
the new norm very much hotter summers
and in some places cold
winters yeah it's the frequency of these
crazy climactic climatic you know
weather-related events that we're seeing
with just more and more regularity yeah
these crazy storms and the impact that
they're having on cities and we're
putting band-aids on these problems by
my observation well the thing is rich
people don't we don't want to confront
one of the biggest things in our own
lives we don't want to confront is death
right people don't talk about death it's
not you know even my parents who are in
their 80s we're talking to them about
doing a well and they were like why
would we do a will we've got years to go
so no one wants to confront their own
death so if we're not willing to
confront our own death it's hard to
confront something as big as the death
of the planet or the death of our
ability to live on the planet so it's a
scare it's a scary thing right so I
understand why people don't want to talk
about it we also don't want to believe
that we have that level of control over
our planet and that if we did have that
level of control that would mean we'd
have to take responsibility and and
taking responsibility it's tough for
many people and and we're in the midst
of a political climate where there's
never been less political will to really
wrestle with this in a meaningful way so
like what is going on at the EPA right
now with Scott Pruett and the Trump
administration and the rollback of all
these initiatives that you were integral
in in sort of you know fostering and
working on during your tenure so it's a
dark time at EPA I really want to give a
shout out to all the people who are
still there in the trenches day after
day doing amazing work we need to send
them a support and love yeah it's like
that thing where do you stay in and work
for change or does that make you you
know part of the problem like it's a
difficult thing like I have compassion
for somebody who's got to be working
there right now thinking why am i you
know employed by this administration
that stands for everything that I've
devoted my life to combat and yet
leaving isn't the salut
either yeah I think it's about
temperament you know people need to
enjoy what they do they're people that I
talk to that like staying and fighting
and doing their job which to me is an
act of resistance and they're people who
are just so depressed they want to curl
up in a ball and you know hibernate for
the next three years so depending on
your disposition if if you're a fighter
and believe that you can make a
difference and stay you should stay if
you're just miserable you should
probably move on right but what's
happening on a larger scale is that
there's been this fight that the
Republicans started way before Trump
within the years of the Obama
administration the Republican Congress
had a ready cut EPA's budget by 25
percent so huge huge budget cuts so by
the time Trump took over they were
already at app have a very minimal
budget and he now wants to cut it back
to really nothing so that budget is one
the next which you pointed out which is
even more troubling is the rollback of
standards so more than 50 different
standards have been rolled back some of
them it's just a press headline and
they're not going to actually
materialize because the courts and the
legal system is gonna stop Trump in his
tracks but he's definitely pandering to
his base his base feel like but for the
EPA but for environmental regulations
everything would be good we have jobs
we'd have all these burgeoning
manufacturing you know unfortunately
what's been ignored is automation which
is the number one job killer in our
country and then the second which Trump
has focused on is outsourcing that
manufacturing to other places the
environment and environmental
regulations has had a net huge positive
on the American economy because worker
productivity is one of the number one
things that you look at in terms of the
health of the economy we're sitting here
in California California has the
strongest environmental regulations of
any state in the Union it also has the
strongest economy of any state in the
Union so this kind of [ __ ] argument
that
you know what environmental regulations
are killing jobs we're like a 4.3
percent unemployment rate right now
mm-hmm
it's this it's this sense that I mean
Pruitt is said sort of famously that the
bounty of the earth is here to feed us
and feel us and anything that stands in
the way of that needs to be eradicated
and it's really a default to this
situation in which you know he would
like to see the industries that are
meant to be policed by the EPA
self-regulating each other will defer to
them and will let them decide you know
what's right in our best interest and
it's just amazing to me that will hurt
that this is this is sort of you know
getting by right now it's a wake-up call
I think we sat on our laurels too long
we had an abundance of confidence that
the system was working and the fact that
you could have someone like Pruitt which
is really the fox guarding the chicken
house be the head of EPA I think was
shocking enough he's very very skilled
he's like you and I he's an attorney he
knows what he's doing he's like a
trained assassin he isn't a bungling
right fool but you know kleh home he
spent a lot of time pursuing the EPA
right like he's very well-versed and the
mechanics of how it functions and yeah
he sued EPA 14 times over numerous
different regulations yeah the state
that we're at is that people when you
polled them when you do public opinion
surveys they say yes we want more
environmental protection we want our air
to be cleaner we want our water to be
cleaner we want the land to be free of
toxins when you then ask them do you
think it's government's role to put more
regulations in place they say no mm
absolutely not rich we don't want that
so you've got this bizarre dichotomy
between on the one hand you want more
protection on the other hand there's a
complete lack of trust in government
institutions so he's you would think
that the person in the role that he is
in would care more about the
institutions and the rule of law so you
know this has become a very partisan
issue unfortunately I have a lot of
Republican friends that don't agree with
what he's doing there's a lot of
fisherman there's a lot of hunters that
are like you know what we need national
parks why we shrinking national parks as
Trump has proposed to do so the whole
litany of things that are happening I
think is going to lead to a backlash it
hasn't happened yet I I would have
predicted it would have happened a
little sooner but I don't you know we're
kind of an uncharted territory when it
comes to this administration right
what's interesting is that the history
of environment environmentalism was
initially a Republican idea I mean it
was Nixon who who created the EPA and
and
my sense is that it was sort of born out
of perhaps an elitist idea like we want
to preserve where we fly fish and you
know we like the views out of our
windows where the Liberals were coming
from a place of thinking look we need to
use this land for you know building
lower income housing for poor people so
it was really a Republican ideal that
initiated this and it's interesting how
that's flipped and maybe that has to do
with you know when did that occur like
was that when Al Gore became vice
presidents or things when Al Gore came
out with an inconvenient truth
originally he came politicized yeah
originally I was looking at this he was
originally slated to do the movie with
John McCain and at some point it became
just about now politically untenable for
John Chapman well I mean if you remember
back in the day even when McCain ran for
president it was still a fairly
bipartisan issue so I think we have a
lot of work to do as a movement and I
actually I blame myself and the movement
in in no small measure forgetting Trump
elective I think the the tone of the
environmental movement's real kind of
shaming of people especially in the Rust
Belt for those people's roles in
environmental pollution which they
really have you know as an individual
people in Michigan for instance or
Pennsylvania I think felt like we're
being patronized we're being talked down
to by these
elites from these environmental groups
if we don't have a Prius if we don't
live in a green home if we don't you
know eat a vegan diet then we're not
good people and we think we are good
people and so inspiring people as as you
do and I'm trying to do around health
this is about health this isn't about
telling someone they should be doing it
for a greater cause let's start with
individual people and what they care
about and we need to just change the
tone
yeah the elitist veneer that washes over
notions related to wellness
environmentalism you know living green
and all of that is not serving the
greater good that you know I agree and
it's the people in the Rust Belt
it's the blue collar you know workers
that are well intentioned and just
trying to live their lives that
ultimately you know sort of need these
ideas the most or are suffering the most
as a result of a lack of understanding
or policies that could enhance their day
to day you know sort of general
well-being yeah this whole vote against
health interest is a bizarre place that
were in I mean many of the people who
voted for Trump it's not in their
self-interest in any way shape or form
and yet they did it because of a belief
that the current system was not helping
them mm-hmm yeah the idea that he was
gonna look out for them that he was
gonna bring jobs back from these old
sort of outdated sectors was pushing a
button that you know they needed to hear
and I don't begrudge them for that like
they're suffering and they're having a
hard time and somebody comes along who's
breaking ranks and and someone who they
feel is speaking to them directly that's
going to activate that you know that
sector for sure
to me it's about getting back to
grassroots that's where that's why
politics and environment and all this
needs to happen it's been so focused on
Washington DC that it's become an
abstraction when we're talking at the
beginning of the the hour about what
climate change is to most people it's
only
when you equate it back to their
situation if the kid has asthma if
they're you know look subject hurricanes
that hit more frequently but making it
this big concept of global climate
change that doesn't really mean anything
so we've abstracted notions of the
environment to such a degree that it
doesn't mean anything to any person and
we need to get back down to a place
where people care about the hills in
Malibu because they hike there people
care about Santa Monica Bay because they
fish there not some abstracted notion
and I I think EPA is partly to blame
we've become so specialized as a society
that individual scientists understand
individual parts of much bigger problems
no one's sitting there explaining this
is this is what's going on this is how
we need to move forward yeah they're not
necessarily communicators in the
broadest sense that's not that's not
their job and it seems like there needs
to be a new way or a reframing of the
vernacular around these ideas so that
people can understand and embrace them
outside the context of of partisan
politics and I think you're right and to
a large extent that is happening Boy
Scout groups still collect bottle and
bottles and cans and get their
Redemption value community groups still
clean up pollution and in rivers lakes
and streams in their park so at the
grassroots level
there's an enormous amount of good stuff
happening and I would encourage people
that that's to me in all in all my life
adventures that's what I've gone back
down to which is this is about you each
of us as individuals and the more it's
about large policies that are driven by
science that people don't understand
that that could work for a while while
there's a reverence and respect for
science I still have that reverence and
respect but most people would put you
know a Nobel laureate scientist on the
same pedestal as Kim Kardashian mm-hmm
yeah but what's interesting about that
is you know this notion of personal
responsibility that's a conservative a
traditional conservative ideal like take
responsive you know and the the greater
good is elevated by the results of you
you know sort of mining your own P's and
Q's I don't believe in in minding my own
P's and Q's in that I think what we've
lost is people knowing who their
neighbors are people building community
and valuing community as opposed to the
individuality that exists with my
relationship with my iPhone that's not
community watching TV is not community
so getting I was just gardening the
other day and I met every single one of
my neighbors cuz I was out on the street
talking to people as opposed to in my
home and just sitting on a stoop people
don't do that so we may never get back
to that place but I'm not suggesting
that this this ideal of retreating into
oneself but but basically if we we are
we are the way that we experience the
planet the planet is incredibly special
and unique and it's a gift and we can't
act firstly as if we're different than
the rest of the planet I mean to me this
myth of human superiority is kind of the
beginning of the end once we think we're
better than and different than every
thing else on the planet we then have as
you described just belief and capacity
to have dominion over nature which is
insane well in history tells us well
that every time we try to outwit nature
nature ultimately in the long run gets
the best of us and that we are longer do
we have to before yeah exactly yeah like
when are we going to finally get that
and try to you know live in a way that's
more copacetic with the ebbs and flows
of what the planet requires I don't
think we will and I don't mean that in
it are you miss doom are you now are you
pessimistic that speaks to your overall
perspective on whether we can win this
war or not I mean I I
we like to think of myself as an
optimist I now I mean both those terms
optimists and pessimists kind of have a
inherent in them of belief in a in a
eventualities that something either
positive will happen or negative for me
I don't see a lot of evidence that you
know I started doing international
environmental law so I thought the way
forward was these big treaties like the
one that Trump pulled out of there
Harris agreement right so when you look
at those agreements most of the
countries we had one we had the Kyoto
Protocol which was meant to curtail
greenhouse gas emissions had strict
criteria and reduction targets they
weren't met when you look at nearly any
treaty of its kind they you know they're
not that they don't have a good track
record so I'm looking for what other the
signs of positive growth for me are
areas like the organic food movement for
instance where it relates to people's
own individual health and well-being
where there's a direct nexus between
them and the environment that's where I
see improvement that's that's where I
want to focus yeah it seems like
changing habits and human nature or
attitudes around these issues are going
to be best driven by changes in people's
specific environments that contribute to
making the better choice as opposed to
the easy lazy choice that that is
creating harm yeah for me I saw that
your wife did a book on dairy-free
cheese like I'm lactose intolerant so
when I eat or consume milk I feel crap I
feel terrible so it isn't you know I I
became kind of an accidental vegan
because my wife when we moved in
together was a vegetarian and I just
started not eating meat if you try and
eat meat five years later it really your
system can't do it right so I never made
any particular choice to go down the
path by daughter then became gluten
fries and I'm like wow how did how do
they end up doing all this but but these
are these are decisions that are
consistent with your values though
because when you look at the impact of
animal agriculture on planetary health
it's pretty dire but so rich this is
exactly the conversation that so if we
analyze this conversation I don't think
you're gonna convince more than 5% of
the population to stop eating meat
because of the massive impacts that
dairy and other agriculture have on you
know just industrial agriculture
generally have a devastating impact on
the planet that's not going to convince
anyone but if you say look how Goodrich
looks you know look how good I feel
and you help someone do that I think
they're gonna change and keep that
change like I'm not going to ever go
back to drinking milk because it makes
me feel terrible now I'm not supposed to
drink milk so allowing people to one
understand how they feel and I think
many people have lost touch have just
become numb cynical unable to understand
and really value how they feel and then
you start eating fried food with that
knowledge and it just tastes [ __ ]
nasty right so they don't do it anymore
as opposed to you should not eat meat
because it's bad for the planet yeah I
get that I get that distinction but I
think environmentally we can create you
know how do we how do we foster the
organic food movement so that it can
impact more people and the people that
need it the most which is the lower
socioeconomic class that either can't
afford it or access it right now and to
me that happens through you know local
urban gardening and programs that start
with kids in schools and education and
all of these things that get people
interested and and and in a communal
sense you were talking about like being
gardening in your front yard like you
know it seems like every city you know
every urban landscape should proliferate
with urban gardens where people can grow
their own food and have access to
organic produce and create an
opportunity for their kids to learn
about
that connection between the foods are
eating and health because these are the
people that are suffering the greatest
from these chronic ailments that are
just killing millions of people 100%
agree a huge advocate of community
agriculture and I once had the cool job
of being the director of the San
Francisco Recreation and Parks
Department and the number one thing that
people came up to me thanking me for was
not how great Golden Gate Park looked it
was thank you so much for having that
community garden
I was sitting six years on a waitlist
now I'm in just getting your hands in
the dirt all those microbes just the
feeling of being out and doing what
we're supposed to do which is be
connected to nature and then being able
to show the kids that connection the
Green Schools movement is an amazing
positive example of what can be done
tearing out the asphalt and putting in
community gardens for flowers for food
in my kids public school in San
Francisco they did that at rooftop and
they had a garden teacher and she was
amazing and it just motivated the kids
to - even though they're in the middle
of a dense City to think about nature in
a different way so for all the people
out there who are doing that keep doing
it you're awesome yeah it's amazing but
the idea that you would have to be on a
waitlist for six years that's insane
right it should be something that's
accessible to everybody especially in
densely populated areas I know there's
some cool stuff happening in Oakland
with this that's cool stuff yeah in LA
in Oakland all all over all over the
country cool stuff is happening but it
takes okay so this is exactly the
emphasis that I think is important which
is we are so frigging distracted by
Trump and national politics which does
not bear really on how many community
gardens they're going to be and yet you
go to these meetings as I did to suggest
that they be more community gardens in
poorer communities no don't one from
national environmental groups shows up
no one five or six members of the
community show up because they're all
King Trump on some you know crazy Fox
News thing they're not there in the
community so we need people to put down
their TVs their phones give up this idea
that they're gonna be able to change
Trump get less anxiety in their life by
doing so and go to these community
meetings and say yeah we can transform
our community one of the great ways of
doing it is by putting in community
gardens right in other words stop
spending so much of your time and
resources and energy in things you can't
control exactly let's take a look at
what we can actually change yep yeah so
how did you get interested in the
environment to begin with I grew up in a
small village in England called
Grantchester with two American parents
so I my number one question is how could
you be an EPA if you have an English
accent I'm like okay you can you can
grow up in another country and be a US
citizen and every morning the cows would
go in front of our house to the meadows
and for me the most liberating thing was
the bicycle so it's a very flat part of
England me and my friends from like six
years old would just go out into the
fields on our bikes on these farm roads
and go for miles and miles and that
sense of liberation and freedom
connected to the environment was really
important
mm-hmm and so that that triggered
something like did you know then like
this is what I want my life to be about
or when did it when did the lights go on
like this is this is a career that I
could pursue so the next thing that I
did was take photographs off trees so
that was my passion when I was maybe 11
through 16 and then my grandmother was
this very very boisterous feisty lady
and she I would argue all the time and
she was like Jared you should go to law
school I'd never even thought about
being a lawyer she was a child
psychologist and maybe she was just kind
of pushing me thinking reverse
psychology but ended up going to law
school and doing human rights law
to Berkeley for Law School yeah and at
Berkeley at the time it was just leading
up to the 1992 Rio Earth Summit which
was the first time the largest gathering
at its time of heads of state that had
ever happened in human history to come
together for the environment and George
Bush Senior was there and even signed
the climate change convention at the
time so it just shows how much has
changed even since 92 anyway they asked
me and this friend Laurie to do a report
for the Sierra Club Legal Defense Fund
on the relationship between human rights
in the environment if your environment
is so destroyed by an oil company or
logging do you have a cause in an
international court to say that your
human rights have been violated and what
it showed was that every constitution
new constitution that either been
written or changed since 1976 included
this clause of a right to a healthy
environment so as is one of the few
constitutions that doesn't have any
rights to a healthy environment
interesting yeah so so that leads you
into ultimately into city politics in
San Francisco though yeah I never
thought I'd become a city bureaucrat I'm
kind of accidental vegan and an
accidental bureaucrat so I know I would
I ran an accidental podcaster and
exactly know now you're forcing me rich
it has to be tied down I've been in this
cabin for four weeks the only way I
could get out was to do a podcast no so
I started just in terms of people
listening
I wouldn't recommend going right into
city government if you care about the
environment think about what you can do
locally I work for environmental groups
the first one was this group called the
Natural Resources Defense Council and
then this group called the International
Fund for Animal Welfare and the funnest
biggest campaign that we ran was
actually the last time I was in Malibu
was with Pierce Brosnan in in like 98 or
something we ran this campaign to stop
Mitsubishi from building a salt factory
twice the size of Washington DC in this
beautiful
place called laguna san ignacio so
fighting corporate evils was how i kind
of got my teeth sharpened and then then
I got this job in San Francisco with
Willie Brown right yeah yeah yeah he's a
character that guy yes you need to get
him on the show rich I would love to I
actually worked in his law firm my first
job out of law school was that a firm
called Blair Mendelsohn in San Francisco
and he was a name partner he wasn't
around that much at the time but I had a
little bit of interaction with him I
mean he's got that guy's got a lot of
swagger he's amazing and if you shake
his hand I saw him a few days ago he's
got a hand of steel he works out every
day two or three hours he told me he
he's he keeps a very strict diet I mean
he's in his early 80s but he looks in
his late 60s he's sort of a man born out
of time too I feel like he would have
flourished in you know the 1920s or he's
a very much above evil yeah you know I
love Willie yeah he's a classic so he
appoints you and you got to work like
you made a pretty significant impact on
a lot of measures in San Francisco like
I read like recycling went from 46%
somewhere in the high 70s or something
like that so yeah we think about
environment so cities so in 2005 for the
first time in human history the majority
of people on the planet live in urban
areas so as a civilization as a species
we spend most of our time as farmers in
wild places then in farms now we live in
cities so 50% of the world's humanity
lives in cities 85% of the world's
pollution comes from cities so some of
these legal instruments that I had kind
of looked at and studied in law school
they don't really apply to cities and
yet cities are where the action is at so
in San Francisco we basically came up
with this theory that if we can't come
up with environmental ordinances and
regulations in San Francisco where else
in the world are they going to be able
right yeah they've got to start there
they have a ball yeah an obligation
rather like so
we're kind of zany so we came out with
this goal in 2001 to get to zero waste
by 2020 the people the people who are
implementing it phoned me the other day
they're like Jared what the [ __ ] how
could you come out zero waste by 2020
were you nuts might we needed a goal
right we shouldn't be sending stuff to
landfill or incineration waste to me is
a design flaw like why do we have waste
as a society we don't need to if we
design things better so we did we were
the first city to do curbside collection
of food scraps to turn into compost
so more than 500 tons a day of food
scraps are turned into organic compost
in San Francisco didn't it didn't
composting become like a legal mandate
yeah so once you set a goal which I'd
encourage everyone in their life in
their business in their cities to do so
zero waste to landfill by 2020 means you
need to work with everyone the
businesses the recycling companies and
come up with a plan how are you gonna do
this so what we realize is at some point
voluntary efforts they'll get you pretty
far
they got us to 70 percent recycling
you're not gonna get to 80 percent so we
went to Gavin Newsome who then became
the mayor so Gavin we need to get 80 90
percent in the next 10 years we can only
do it if we make these things mandatory
and people kind of freaked out we also
then looked at what is the stuff that's
still going to landfill that can't be
recycled so plastic bags styrofoam we
like we need to ban that and I'm not you
know you know there's a lot of things
that don't need to be banned but some
things do plastic bags are one of them
we had a huge fight with a plastic bag
industry but it kind of inspired people
to if we can do this rich in these
communities and now as a state then the
rest of the nation can say you know what
it is possible we actually can do it the
same has been true with solar power the
same has been true with many different
initiatives if California can do it and
make
affordable the rest of the nation will
follow it's been true of electric
vehicles
well it's certainly true of plastic bags
I mean as audacious as that may have
sounded at the time I mean you guys were
the first put that in motion and now
there's a cascading effect of that like
that's now everyone sort of understands
and accepts that plastic bags are bad
and you know I don't know how the laws
look across the country but you know
you're see fewer and fewer them for sure
and it people always say you know what
Jared this is absurd why focus on one
little thing like the plastic bag but we
want to be able to show that we can make
a difference no one needs plastic bags
and it's important to have those
victories as an environmental community
we've very very focused on these are the
problems the victories we also need to
savor and realize you know for instance
in San Francisco we had legislation
though all buildings every single
building have to now be LEED which is a
green building standard gold Wow saying
every new building that's built or all
buildings that exists all new buildings
that have built and if you level the
playing field people sign up they say
you know what we want to build green and
we have to build green so we will so
people are just looking when it back to
the Prewitt example you know what we're
not here to make sure the industry can
make more money by polluting we're here
to make sure that industry knows the
rules and regulations that are set to
protect public health and the
environment and that balances coexisted
for a long time and and I met with
industry upon industry when I was the
EPA and most of them I would say 90 to
95 percent want to do the right thing
but if you come to them and say rich we
can cut all these environmental
regulations are UN they'll be like sure
yeah we're gonna make a bit more money
but it's not sustainable in the long
term and and the sustainability movement
in large corporations even large
corporations like Walmart and Apple
they're they're here for to stay and
they when Trump was suggesting that we
pull out of Paris like why would you do
that are you crazy so industry by and
large is for environment
action yeah it's in their long-term
interest I mean you can make short-term
profits short-term gains by cutting
corners but you know I think we're in
this very transparent culture now the
Internet has afforded us the tools to
really understand how how you know
corporate America functions in a way
that wasn't possible you know 10 15
years ago even and I think we have a
maturing generation of Millennials who
care very much about these things and
they're they want to patronize the
companies that they know are paying
attention to these sorts of things so to
the extent that a company can be a
little bit more profitable in the short
run ultimately you know we can trust on
the flow of information to let people
know who's doing well who isn't and I
think we have a groundswell of interest
in the consumer base that that really
wants to patronize the companies that
are doing well and reward them so I
think it is in you know it is it is very
much in you know in an entity's
capitalistic long-term interest to get
on board with these ideals the great
example of that is the no GMO label on
the fair trade label which haven't been
legislated on it's voluntary
yeah there's voluntary but when you read
it one do people really want to eat food
that has GMOs in it not really you know
the labeling I think has actually gone
beyond most people's expectations it
would been great if we could have
outlawed some GMOs and really given a
boost to fair trade but those labels are
doing a great job and consumers as you
said they want to buy into those values
and know that the products that they're
consuming have a value proposition that
they can buy into right back to the
plastic bag thing the plastic bag to me
is sort of symbolic it's as a
representative of single-use items in
general and and this seems to be you
know really one of the biggest problems
are sort of disposable culture whether
it's a bottled water or a plastic bag or
you know a cup at Starbucks whatever
whether they're recyclable or not
plastic paper whatever we're just in
donated that we can just buy something
use it once and throw it away and and
we're just sitting on top of just just
inconceivable amounts of waste so how
are we you know how can we move forward
from this gigantic problem I mean the
bag thing is a huge victory and you're
seeing that but like what about bottled
water for example or what are the other
things that are contributing to this
problem and you know the the gigantic
Pacific Garbage Patch and you know all
of these issues that we now have to
contend with yeah it's kind of
insurmountable but but the way to do it
is small piece at a time so back in the
1970s the environmental movement was
kind of founded on the 3 R's reduce
reuse recycle we focus a lot of our
attention on recycling so when you go
and meet with Arrowhead or Nestle
they'll tell you the the single use
bottles rich they're recyclable and the
problem is that a billion of them a year
end up in landfill and beaches in
California so they're not on tree they
may be recyclable but do you need them
in the first place so we kind of have
become slaves to this concept of
convenience if you know if you get
takeout food you're gonna get destroy
you're gonna get the cutlery you're
gonna get all these things you really
don't need because you have them in your
house and yet they keep coming so I
think the next big trend is for
ordinances Alameda County which is where
Berkeley and Oakland are up in northern
California just passed an ordinance to
have an opt-in for straws so rather than
getting a straw that's plastic with a
wrapper on it you have to ask someone
for a straw and just that single act of
rather than being giving it given it
automatically asking someone is is
actually I think a really positive move
the other thing that San Francisco is
looking at is both fees if you want to
get a Starbucks cup and you can't be
bothered to bring your own you should
maybe pay more and then the last thing
is require
some kind of reuse option so if you're
getting food for a delivery service like
caviar they should probably provide an
option 1 you have to opt in for the
straws the cutlery and all that stuff
but more importantly that there's an
option for a tray that you put the food
in that they take back right yeah that
would be great
I mean I and it doesn't seem like that
big of a deal to kind of put that in
motion I'm working on it you are ha ha
that's good so there's some really cool
things happening with the zero waste
movement right now I was meant to just
last week have this woman on who's who
goes by trashes for tossers on the
internet and like it yeah she's cool
she's uh you have to know you have to
grown up in England to know why yeah
although I don't think she's not British
though she lives in New York and she's
got four years of her waist in one mason
jar you could also have waist is for
wankers now that would be good too
there's a male version of her exactly
yeah so she like has out for years going
and all of her waist is in one mason jar
and you know sort of blogs and vlogs
about like how to live a zero-waste
lifestyle and open this store in
Brooklyn called package free shop where
you need to bring your own you just
everything is in bulk and then bins
right so you bring in your own stuff and
you can refill and you know all of that
and she shows you how to make your own
shampoo and all that kind of stuff and
that's another thing that I think it's
awesome I love that it's very cool yeah
and it's it's very much a millennial
thing I think but it's also goes back to
that point you referenced earlier which
is to expect that I mean it's inspiring
to see that you can do that and it makes
you think more about the ways that you
generate but how many people are
actually going to adopt that lifestyle
which most people would look at is very
aesthetic and challenging versus
creating whether it's regulations or
just simply an environment that's more
conducive to creating less waste and
disposing of less waste
yeah regulations have gotten a bad name
I just think of them as standards or
rules that
that helped reduce pollution and we the
I spent a lot of time looking at the
Pacific Garbage Patch I flew out to
Midway Island I've you know talked to
scientists in Hawaii it is twice the
size of Texas between here and Hawaii
twice the size I heard it was the size
of Texas twice twice the size of Texas
and you know the plastic gets smaller
and smaller and smaller and it ends up
in teeny little beads that that
replicate plankton the fishes then eat
the plastic the plastic not only is just
there which is bad but within the ocean
it creates kind of a magnified impact
and sucks in toxins within the ocean so
they become very toxic the fish when you
do the the liver samples it looks like
you know they've been drinking whiskey
for the last 60 years I mean they're
really bad shape and for what so that we
can have a straw in our Pepsi could we
just not drink it in a class that can go
into a dishwasher I mean yeah I agree
with you we we're not the movement needs
people like the no packaging store in
Brooklyn because we need to understand
what is possible but it isn't going to
be the whole answer right have you seen
it the the patch yourself have you flow
have emitter so it's a bit of a myth in
that it's like a GU right it's not like
no garbage it's very very different
sized pieces of plastic if you can
imagine a tight bottle you know the
first year you have a tight bottle it's
gonna look pretty much like that the
next year it's gonna go into a few
pieces 10 years from now it's gonna be a
lot of small red orange pieces of
plastic and it's going to continue going
down into the water column so you can
find pieces of plastic 60 feet down in
the water column all the way to the
surface so it isn't a blanket surface of
plastic that you can see I work with
NASA and this guy Pete worden who ran
aims to is there a way of flying over
and getting UV or other infrared and
bouncing it to see where the plastic is
there and you can't the way that they
measure it is by on boats they have a
pole basically a sieve that they drag
along behind them and you can see where
the concentration levels are and that's
how they came out with twice the size of
Texas
is there any strategy for dealing with
this thing so there's basically three
strategies one is upstream so if you
think about how we design products we're
just talking about it how you design
products that have less waste less waste
inherently in them like we've all
received those little SIM cards in
blister packs that are huge like what
happens to all that plastic why do we
need all that plastic so design stuff
with zero waste in mind then ii actually
la is a world leader on which is
stopping the plastic from going in from
the streets into the storm drains into
the ocean that that's kind of the number
one inflection point if you don't stop
it going down the drain
it's gonna end up in the ocean so la has
put in all kinds of cool devices to
capture the plastic and then the third
is to go out and actually collect it and
there's some noble efforts going on
there's a young Dutchman who's working
on this so there's some cool efforts
there's a lot more money unfortunately
being spent on the idea of cleanup then
there is prevention
exactly isn't there some really young
kid I was just reading yeah like 16 year
old kid who figured out some wizard who
figured out how to decompose this and uh
yeah we love it we love inventions and
cool stuff and and so he's attracting a
lot of Buuren bork i think his name is
anyway it's very cool i wish him all the
best luck we there's about 10 million
tons of plastic a year that's being
added to the Pacific Garbage Patch so
our main goal should be doing all three
it's like an all-of-the-above strategy
if we just focus on cleanup
you know a terrifying thing that I found
when I was in Taiwan is that they built
all their landfills right on the
oceanfront and now with raising sea
levels because of climate change these
huge landfills are being washed into the
ocean so another thing which I think is
fairly common sensical is maybe we
should have an international agreement
to not build landfills within a mile of
the ocean yeah how does that even happen
that's amazing well I think you know in
a broader sense it speaks to human
beings kind of default default kind of
expectation that that technology is
going to innovate us out of all the
problems that we create for ourselves
whether it's Elon Musk getting us to
Mars so we can just punt on this planet
like like the idea of terraforming Mars
like oh that's awesome well why don't we
tariffs terraform the earth like if we
agreed if we had that technology can't
we use that year and like protect what
we're actually doing rather than saying
well we're just gonna we're just gonna
rifle through all of this and we'll
figure it out later is like you know
it's this is not working for us yeah I
have a very complex relationship with
technology in that for instance if you
look at solar cells back in 1979 it
costs $80 to produce a watt of energy
now it's about 55 cents mm-hmm so
technology has allowed us to capture
this renewable resource the Sun and wind
and battery storage is going to allow us
to keep it in our homes and use it when
we need it so there are there are
elements of technology which are really
useful electric cars for instance
they're a complex one I live in San
Francisco we can't have any more cars it
doesn't matter what you know if it's a
hydrogen fuel cell car or our hybrid it
doesn't make any difference there's no
room for cars and those cars take a lot
of energy to produce a lot of energy to
deconstruct and they kill a lot of
people so maybe walking like I was
always like why why is no one promoting
walking and bicycling and and cities
that's not as sexy as a Tesla s exactly
isn't
but you get sexier by doing them right
and you already walk five miles you or
you were walking five miles to and from
work every day when I yeah I decided to
do this to leave work and do the Pacific
Crest Trail I needed to practice write
practice you're walking yeah we do and
we we were designed to walk right I mean
we're not designed to sit on our ass and
get fat we're designed to walk that
basically that's why we stand on two
feet unlike other animals so we're
designed to walk I love walking
why isn't solar more ubiquitous there's
I was reading yesterday that there's a
hundred trillion dollars as excuse me
there's a hundred trillion dollars of
stranded assets that the old status quo
energy companies have namely they built
power plants that are running on coal
even natural gas that solar if it were
as ubiquitous as you and I would like
would mean they are paying for a
stranded asset that doesn't get money
and so these big utilities that you hear
saying lots of good things even in our
state they have a very strong interest
to continue their power plants going so
you know the price the price of end of
new power I don't think anyone in the
United States no matter what Trump says
is going to build a new coal-fired power
plant coal is just too expensive yeah
and the reason it's too expensive
unfortunately is fracking so fracking
you know the upside of fracking is that
it put coal out of business the bad side
is there has very significant
environmental impacts so solar now is
competitive and that's a fantastic thing
unfortunately Trump put tariffs right on
Chinese imports of solar panels they're
more people involved in installing solar
now in America than there are coal
miners so it spectacular
I mean this is this has to be the future
it is the future right whether whether
the coal and gas companies like it or
not Soula is the future as with other
renewable energy like wind and I would
imagine with the the advances in the
batteries that we're seeing right now
that it's got to be even way more
effective now what they're capable of
doing even compared to a couple years
ago I was just in a new Chevy bolt they
have the Volt and the jolt and the bulk
yeah okay they get kind of confusing
it's actually a cool little car and it
has a 320 mile range right a few years
ago they're the first one that volt had
like a 60 mile range so the battery
technology is taking it yeah that's
crazy it doesn't make sense to me at all
like why anybody would build combustion
engine cars at all anymore it just
doesn't seem to be it's it's not the
future yeah the head of GM went to China
I think she was expecting to be able to
convince them that internal combustion
engines the normal gasoline engines was
still part of a future mix she came back
and said no right yeah electric vehicles
for GM everyone else is is here to stay
it's our future it seems that in certain
respects China sort of leading the way
they are and they aren't I mean they
they have a very disciplined Central
Command government so when they decide
to do something like I don't really yeah
just gets done when we decide we're
gonna do high-speed rails we did ten
years ago in California nothing gets out
four years later we're still exactly
which is unfortunate I wish I could have
taken the train down here I'm in two
hours so the the thing that they're
doing right is they're moving in the
right direction they still have a very
very high reliance on old cheap coal
which burns you know very dirtily
most of that coal is in manufacturing
products that we buy so one of the
things I thought would be cool at some
point is to have a label that shows you
the energy source of the product that
you're
mm-hmm so you know we kind of buy it
blindfolded and think oh you know what
I'm not exactly sure where this was made
but I'm sure if I bought it on Amazon it
must be good it's probably coming from
China made in a factory with a lot of
coal energy shipped here you know a huge
amount of California's pollution still
is from cargo ships coming from China
right that has very very high sulfur
fuel yeah it seems like there should be
the equivalent of a nutrition facts
panel on every consumer product that
explains to you the the carbon footprint
of the creation and distribution the
shipping of that product let's do it
rich yeah I mean the cool thing about
California so we have Jerry Brown an
amazing guy I love our current governor
I think we're likely to have Gavin
Newsom as our next governor and if you
put those standards in place in
California state with 40 million people
and the fifth largest economy on the
planet it doesn't really matter what
Washington DC says it doesn't really
matter what Trump says if you can get it
done in Sacramento it's gonna happen
around the country because they're not
going to put that they're not going to
take that panel with all that
environmental information off it on the
ones that they sell in Nevada or North
Dakota or Massachusetts it's gonna be
the same same exact product so I think a
lot of thinking needs to be done about
how we leverage California even more
than we have already
to get environmental change in the
entire country right because California
really is the ultimate test case for not
just the rest of the country but the
rest of the world because there is so
much sensibility around these issues
absolutely and I mean people live in
this state because they like the
outdoors because they want to spend time
nearly year-round being able to run and
hike and swim and so that's a certain
group of people those people vote those
people are going to vote for more
environmental protections and that's why
you have the state people often ask me
why is California so green
it's a self-selecting group of people
that live here
and you know I love living here
so you after your tenure with the city
you're appointed to the EPA by Obama to
basically run what is it called region 9
section 9 yeah
district 9 mr. B about South Africa that
call yeah the dystopian yes that's why I
told close friends and family it's
district 9 its region 9 yes yeah it was
California Arizona and Nevada Hawaii and
Pacific Islands and what was your charge
like what was that job all about so that
job if if you go back to something you
mentioned earlier so back in the
seventies Richard Nixon unbelievably
created the Environmental Protection
Agency is wild oh yeah excellent isn't
that yeah
what was going on what motivated him to
do that a lot of it also reflecting back
and what we just said came from
California so California was going ahead
and saying particularly la the air is so
bad we need to do something about this
and people around the country it was a
grassroots movement they're like screw
this like less DC does something we're
gonna do it ourselves and they were
doing it themselves and there it got to
this point where the president you know
we had the first Earth Day rally in
April 22nd 1970 there were
demonstrations around the country this
was a big big political issue and
actually it kind of relates to China in
China this is a very big political issue
people cannot breathe and the middle
class is growing and growing and growing
and they're like this will become such a
big issue that the Chinese politicians
are worried that it will topple them so
that's why they're tackling it and the
same was true in the US in the 1970s so
the job really was to implement the big
environmental statutes that Congress
passed so Congress and the president
passed the Clean Air Act and so then up
to EPA working with in this case the
state of California or Nevada or Arizona
to implement it and that means you know
one of the most important things is
getting the science right
so science is not a belief system right
it is the world outside that can be
measured and that measurement can be
repeated you'll get the same answer so
science is incredibly important to the
environmental protection of our planet
we need to know exactly how good is the
air how good is the water if they're
contaminants going into the air and
water that we can't see it doesn't mean
they're not going to hurt us a lot of
what we can't see hurts us very badly
so we would do enforcement actions we
would take actions against polluting
companies were involved for instance in
the big case against VW who had a whole
scandal of you know their emissions
testing requirements you know so we we
kept people honest I always saw us as
the environmental cop on the beat and
that cop is no longer on the beat and
that that's something that worries me so
whether it's a big oil refinery in
Torrance that might blow up has blown up
if it's you know the the big gas leak
that you had just a few years ago in
Southern California EPA and other
agencies are there to one stop it to
clean it up and then three hold those
polluters accountable mm-hmm so the rule
of law science and transparency you are
kind of the most important things to me
and that's when you asked if I had
heartburn and that's what gives me heart
but now we have no idea what EPA is
doing it's all behind closed doors
they're not talking to the scientists
the people with real knowledge there was
recently a pesticide that had gone
through years and years of review
chlorpyrifos and the staff brought it up
to prove it and said we should delicious
and he's like no we're gonna keep it on
the shelves right it'd been established
that it was harming children exactly but
and not I mean people need to realize
that by science we're talking about
peer-reviewed science this isn't one
study that one person did this is
academic studies that have been done
replicated in many cases by very
prestigious universities
and then are reviewed by an independent
federal panel and then go to EPA so by
the time we got them this was so vetted
yes and it's not a conjecture at this
point it's not I never saw it as really
any discretion I wasn't there to say I'm
a better scientist than they are I mean
Pruitt is not a scientist by his own
admission and yet to just throw that
science away and say yeah hmm yeah maybe
hurting kids maybe hurting kids rich but
we really need to look out for the
chemical companies I mean what about
them I mean it was so absolutely
insidious meanwhile he built like he
built this crazy soundproofing office
for him $25,000 I mean this guy's
bananas yeah he also spent $200,000 on a
contract to go through EPA employees
emails to look at those that weren't
disloyal to Trump oh my god I mean if
you read about it in a in a dystopian
you know novel you'd be like okay no
one's gonna do that kind of [ __ ] so yeah
it's it's crazy town so thank God we're
here in Malibu yeah so anyway all right
so you're at EPA and you're you were
very much from what I understand like a
boots on the ground guy like you're
you're showing up at the wetlands with
your boots on you're you know at these
mines you know firsthand I love the
outside yeah yeah I didn't want to be in
the office what was the the sort of you
know craziest thing that you saw that
even you thought like I can't even
believe this is happening there's so
much oh my god actually I spent a lot of
time at the us-mexico border and because
we're Americans we generally think that
things run from north to south but all
the rivers on the us-mexico border run
from south to north and I was in there's
this border town Calexico and Mexicali
so Mexicali it's about town of a million
people there they had abbatoirs having
pure blood effluent going into rivers
that then went into the US then went
into the Salton Sea just
I have these pictures of these flows of
blood and like like animal blood yeah
I'm just from their cattle industry or
from runoff from slaughterhouses a
slaughterhouse yeah so a slaughterhouse
so this is a big flow of just imagine
like putrid blood coming out of a pipe
going to a river and then talking to the
Congress people on the US side and
saying you know what we need a joint
task force to look at how we can do this
they're like why would why would we care
about what's happening in Mexico well
the Mexican pollution is coming into the
US but you know the other the other big
things just looking at mining the the
mining operations that gold ring they we
have on our fingers takes tons and tons
and tons and tons of digging and or just
the footprints the the scale of these
mining operations is just mind-boggling
yeah I mean what about the the minerals
in our iPhone yeah god you don't even
want to go there because they come from
like the Congo and you know places where
if you have a sort of a Blood Diamond
movie yes yeah it's it's not a pretty
picture that and and frankly you know to
me if you if you look at San Diego and
then Tijuana that is a difference that
environmental regulation makes that's
the most graphic example that I've ever
seen there's a border the thing that
makes America great is partly our
environmental protections that's what
the quality of life that we enjoy that
we can breathe the air that you can turn
on the faucet and get water that you
drink we have spent billions of dollars
to allow that so back to the earlier
point if you can drink this incredible
water out of the tap why are we buying a
bottle of water covered in plastic
that's been sitting in a shelf that
water quality is terrible
yeah because we've been led to believe
through some very convincing marketing
tactics that it's pure that it has a
special mineral content
that's better for us or any number of
factors that would lead us to purchase a
bottle of water that's in a plastic
bottle that comes from some Polynesian
island that had to travel you know 5,500
miles to get here yeah so just realize
it's can we trust it but there's there's
I think there's a there's a public
mistrust of tap water you probably know
more about tap water than then almost
anyone I know a lot about families so
let's talk about tap water okay tap
water other than federal highway system
the second number what the second
largest investment of federal dollars is
in our drinking water infrastructure so
the standards for drinking water are set
scientifically they are very very
rigorous and there are communities that
don't meet them and EPA takes action
against those and the the state of
California and other states also take
action so it's very highly monitored the
standards are very high when it comes to
bottled water that isn't true
so unfortunately tests have been done
and the Food and Drug Administration
oversees bottled water not EPA and the
standards that they use a much lower so
the phthalates the PCBs all the issues
that we would of plastic that we
wouldn't want to leach in our drinking
water if it sits there for a long time
can become an issue BPA so I am always
much more comfortable drinking tap water
than I am bottled water and we've paid
for that system if someone told you that
you could get a glass of water for a
fraction of one cent or you could pay
two dollars for that same glass just
from a fiscal responsibility
you know the drinking water companies
want to sell you on this like 20 years
ago people would have frigging laughed
in your face rich rich I'm gonna sell
you this bottle of water you'd be like
what a bottle of water you're trying to
sell this to me but I think it speaks to
an erosion of trust in government and
when I see what Pruitt is up to and I
see how he just sort of
allowed this pesticide that's been
established to harm children he's made
it permissible for for use
well those pesticides you know are in
our farmland and then there's runoff and
then you know that runoff leads to our
water table and our rivers and
ultimately our drinking water I just had
a guy here on the podcast last week who
was talking about the extent to which
glyphosate is is basically ubiquitous
everywhere because it's use is so
profligate that it's it's in our it's in
our rain and then it rains even on
organic farms it's raining into the soil
and then this ends up in our drinking
water and so there's a bit like and me
not knowing anything I'm like alright
well how much of these pesticides are
actually ending up in our drinking water
is is my drinking water laced with
glyphosate even a you know to the
smallest extent or some other cocktail
of pesticides and that lack of knowing
and distrust that's compounded by you
know what I'm seeing going on in
government right now that motivates me
to buy bottled water right yeah and
there's a lot of people pushing you in
that direction just from a marketing
perspective I mean there's billions of
dollars that are spent on marketing
beverages and none that spent on telling
you the benefits of drinking water so
it's it's not an even playing field and
there I completely agree with you that
the erosion of trust in government has
made people think you know what we had
Flint Michigan Governor he was there and
that drinking water was completely
contaminated and it was and our problems
are not solved no it's still not solved
and in California a million people today
will go without access to water that
meets federal drinking water standards
they're mainly in the San Joaquin Valley
in the Coachella Valley but those people
deserve the same level of drinking water
that all of us deserve so yeah there's a
lot of it's complex being alive in 2018
because there's so many confounding and
often contradictory pieces of
information and
no one knows what to do with it and to
me the only answer is to just live more
simply you know you you from a drinking
water perspective you do need to know
what's in it and you can find out
because we live in a country where that
data is available so you can find out
from your local water utility are there
any issues of concern that I should be
aware of and they will tell you and if
you know your water utilities doing a
good job they should be telling you
anyway so what were some of the
victories that you had during your time
at EPA I think the main victories were
getting people to believe that the
system was there for them especially
poorer people this is concept
unfortunately of environmental injustice
so when you do a search by zip code of
where people live where poor minority
people live in our country is where all
the worst environmental contamination is
and really that their only ways to
address that is one focus on enforcement
make sure the companies clean up their
act and secondly give money to those
communities to help them become the next
solar leaders so there's a belief that
that's kind of compounded unfortunately
by the facts that if you're poor and you
want to get into solar or you want to
get a job at Tesla you're gonna be the
last one to do it right and so helping
the next generation of people who need
to help most get it first was really I
think the biggest victory of helping
empower those communities yeah I know
you worked a lot with various tribal
communities right yeah it was that about
so under the federal and our
Constitution tribes are separate
sovereign nations we you know the first
and probably worst genocide that's
happened in our country before settlers
came on the Mayflower there's a hundred
million Native Americans living in North
America now there's
1.5 million so that that genocide was
was really brutal it it led to people
being herded into reservations those
reservations were then given rights it
basically means that tribes don't need
to and don't are not subject to state
jurisdiction so in many states that's
why they can have casinos mm-hmm those
states do have to apply federal
environmental laws so we were basically
there to support those sovereign nations
do they had community gardens they had
water treatment systems so I decided to
go and meet with all 135 tribes
and go to their every single one of them
every single one individually
individually yeah so I got in I've
rented vehicles and criss-crossed
over seven years met with 135 amazing
amazing experience when you think about
resiliency and what it means to be human
and to keep a language intact to can to
keep ceremonies and a sense of self when
you're Biraj killed you know
annihilated by by an incoming unfriendly
community is incredible to think that in
2018 we still have that so it was it was
a pretty is a profound experience
meeting with them I would imagine you
know delicate as well like you're coming
in as a representative of the United
States government into territory that is
theirs and you know without knowing more
or who you are specifically there's
going to be a reticence like oh this
guy's going to come in and tell us what
we can and can't do you have to overcome
that first of all I had to overcome it
personally because that legacy is
hideous and it isn't a distant history I
spoke to I was recently hiking down in
the Havasupai reservation I met with
this guy clay Bravo
a member of the Hualapai tribe and he
was like his parents were taken to what
he called concentration camps 50 years
ago so this isn't like ancient history
so yeah it was it felt really weird to
be a representative of and from their
perspective and and history historical
perspective of an occupying force I'm
Jewish so I kind of always thought you
know if the Nazis had won that's me
knocking on the the the Jewish homes
door right well this is intense so yeah
there's a lot of suspicion which is
healthy and warranted and on their part
and you know of all the agencies EPA was
the most trusted had the best
relationship with the tribes I think
there's some other great agencies and
then some other less good agencies so
yes it was always it was always I never
took it for granted that I would be
welcome and you know it took time to
build trust and what what are the fruits
of those meetings those encounters like
what did that translate into progressive
reform or anything like that
so I think as a movement I don't take
credit for this but as a movement what
you saw at the Dakota access pipeline
was a coming together of different
tribes and that hadn't really happened
to that extent before the last time it
happened was in Alcatraz in 1969 when
tribes came together and you had their
American Indian Movement
so the Dakota access pipeline battle
which had a horrible end with Trump but
the positive part of that was really
people realizing exactly that cohesion
and sense of community and shared
destiny amongst different tribes so you
ultimately decide to part ways with the
EPA you had like seven months left on
your term or something like that why'd
you decide to leave so I at the time I
thought that Hillary Clinton would win
as many of us did
and I knew that I didn't want to get
reappointed that I done my my job and as
I said earlier I kind of I never I I
never felt like a bureaucrat and yet I
was becoming one and so I knew I just
needed to kind of get out and I didn't
really know what that escape hatch
looked like but when I had always
dreamed of doing the Pacific Crest Trail
that that runs from Mexico to Canada and
so when I talked to my wife about doing
it about me doing it she was like I want
if you're gonna do it you need to do it
this year I'm in the year that I left as
opposed to after Obama leaves so I was
like okay and I did really want to do it
so it was kind of a for me a kind of
difficult act of just jumping off the
precipice and saying you know what I'm
not I don't have another job I don't
have anything lined up but I know that
I'm pretty far away from who I used to
be and think I still AM mm-hmm so you
decide you're gonna do this I mean
that's a monumental undertaking I can't
begin to understand the intricacies of
what it would require to tackle
something like that my only my main
frame of reference is probably like
everybody you know the wild book and and
the movie that followed but what was it
like to prepare for that and and
undertake it well I was saying to David
Elia you know ultimately I think I must
have been and still kind of Harbor this
like an accomplishment junkie because
why couldn't I have just taken a nice
walk in Yosemite like why did I need to
go and do the talking like excited I
told you yeah I was like why did rich
need to do five Iron Man's in a row
because it had to be done yeah well I'm
not it maybe it did maybe it didn't like
yeah it beat the [ __ ] out of me to do
the Pacific Crest Trail and I know that
I needed that I needed to like the
baptism by fire I I was kind of in a rut
and I think I judged success
according to very narrow parameters and
those parameters told me you know and
ever basically that the more scale that
you had in a job if you had more people
to help do more good things you would
get more good things done and it was a
little bit of a myth that I perpetrated
against myself so I am yeah the main
thing I became a planner so planning for
the Pacific Crest Trail
so it's 2,600 miles basically a marathon
every day for a hundred days and that
requires a lot of logistics around food
especially being vegan you're not gonna
get it at a 7-eleven at a Chevron
station you know in the middle of
nowhere so you have to send it to
yourself I became pretty pretty much a
gearhead and the goal was to get the
gear as light as possible so how many
like what are the intervals at which you
could mail stuff to yourself to pick up
along the way I had 31 31 different
drops yeah uh-huh so other people had
that people who did it and had six if
you guys would you have to pack out four
so that whole planning it's really
bizarre because you don't you basically
have to work out how many miles are
going to walk and then you can see how
far the drop places are between so for
instance if it's a hundred miles apart
between a and B and I'm only working ten
miles a day that would take me 10 days
so then I need to pack ten days of food
to get there but you're looking at four
or five days maybe yes mm-hmm
so you had to have enough that's the
amount of food that you had to be able
to carry with you at all times
yes mm-hmm and so what was the food that
you brought so the food that I brought I
read this old school book that was
written in the 70s and I kind of very
intentionally did
want to be inundated by other people's
adventures so the book that I read so
you didn't read Wilde and now I didn't
read world I read this book by Ray
Jardine called like a guide to the
Pacific Crest Trail he was like the
first person then really had done it and
he suggested that I only bring corn
pasta which turned out to be a very bad
idea one I didn't like corn pasta too
there unfortunately the learning
experience the first 700 miles of the
Pacific Crest Trail is the desert so
there's not a lot of water and the water
that you cook the pasta in you have to
throw away right so it was a complete
the worst possible thing so I
immediately switched to ramen which
isn't super healthy I ended up eating
like the the mountaineering food
backpackers pantry and those kind of
foods they actually have some really
good vegan options amazingly and my
favorite one ended up being pad thai
just tastes so good I'd have peanut but
a lot of peanut butter a lot of trail
mix that I made for myself that probably
was the lifeblood yeah but I and bars
look ridiculous number of bars I then
could never eat again they're so right
revolting - I like just look at them I
have a reaction like any I can fairly
bars anymore that's disgusting
yeah so yeah you get to a point you're
just like please do not share so there
are people who do the Pacific Crest
Trail that eat out of the hiker boxes so
these boxes so at post offices or
wherever you get them there's a box and
you put the stuff that you don't want so
as the trail went on I see I have more
and more of the bars in it and people
just like they were throwing this away
so yeah I I probably I think I ate about
two and a half thousand calories a day
and I burnt about five and a half
mmm so you must have dropped quite a bit
of weight yeah and so you'd have to
bring five days of water with you no you
you get the water as you go oh you do
take it from the streams you take it
from horse troughs whatever is there
you clean it yeah amazing there's a
thing called a soya filter the filter
thing yeah credible I mean right this
thing is revolutionized it it weighs
maybe three ounces and you have a little
plastic bag you collect the water and
then you squeeze it into your bottle
right so all told this took you how long
it took me a month and five days uh four
months and five days that would be a
well track that you were running you
know three hour marathon sir yeah yeah
Wow
and and I have sort of two things I want
to know the first thing is the obvious
question which is you know what was the
hardest part or did you have a breaking
point with it or did you you know have
any kind of hair-raising you know
scenarios that arose every day I had
both you mean late just to know that the
it was a rut and emotional much more
emotional rollercoaster than a physical
one so the physical stuff really happens
in the first two weeks so your feet
you're getting used to it my feet went
from a size 10 to a size 11 they'll
never go back and unfortunately like the
shoe sizes so I lost toenails and all
kinds of stuff but really after two
weeks you you're pretty good all right
so my daughter came home from school and
just flicked on the AC and it caused a
buzzing so we took a break but we're
back what were we talking about PCT ect
we were in the middle of you explaining
just the overall harrowing nature of the
entire thing it was fun I mean I don't a
it was a challenge every day every day
at around five o'clock I was just like I
want to [ __ ] go home I hate this and
it was mainly around food like food
becomes was my thing I thought about the
it's the biggest distraction it wasn't
missing family it wasn't I wish it was I
wish I could say I just miss my kids and
wife so much that I do love them but I
didn't miss him on the trail I missed
food like yeah I wanted scrambled eggs
I wanted french toast and I wanted
pancakes with blueberries and I could
eat like like when the PCT hike has come
to town to these teeny little towns
where we got the resupply so you'd I
didn't I'm not sure how I miss this rich
but till you have 31 drops and most of
them are about 10 miles from the trail
so you have to hitchhike
yeah I did like 62 hitches and in very
very very rural parts of the state of
the three states California Oregon and
Washington and universally the nicest
people I never waited more than ten
minutes I'm sure they're used to it
cause everyone's doing that all the time
there yeah it was still really but but
aren't you in towns where you could go
to a restaurant yeah so you could eat
you could learn it but that's every
seven days right yeah so that's when I
would but then the rest of the time that
you you just dream of the next time you
can eat uh-huh food what about like
contending with weather and wild animals
and all of that it was all fine so the
weather the worst weather was in
Washington and in Southern California so
I'm just not used to dealing with like a
hundred and ten degree heat so I had an
umbrella a UV umbrella that for me was a
lifesaver if there's one piece of
equipment other than you know my shoes
and and the usual things umbrella and
walking sticks uh-huh so did you you
hold an umbrella to detach your head and
neither so I kind of jerry-rigged it
into the breast pocket on my I had a
shirt with a breast pocket on the right
and and then I pulled the backpack the
top backpack strap over it so I kind of
I canopy over yourself
anyone who's hiking in the desert there
was enough the number one issue of I saw
maybe
five or six helicopter rescues was all
from being overexposed to the Sun and
dehydration so when you're out there
it's serious the Sun is so powerful in
places like the Mojave Desert you need
an umbrella
yeah no mountain lions or anything like
that yeah they're all kind of a lot of
snake a lot of rattlesnakes bears there
coyotes
a few mountain lions but you know they
generally want to leave you alone yeah
well on a bigger issue I think I'm
interested in hearing a little bit about
what it's like to spend that much time
alone like the self reflection like
especially you being at this point in
your life where you've left this one
career you're trying to figure out what
you want to do with yourself next like
how did that that rumination like kind
of impact your life and sense of self I
mean at first I thought I was going
crazy because there's all these voices
in my head and you've I felt completely
schizophrenic I had like the the Jarrod
I thought was normal Jarrod and then I
had like teenage Jarrod and you know I
had like 15 voices in my head the first
week and I was like oh my god I'm never
gonna make it through because you're
spending all this time by yourself and
my only practice was to work out what I
was thinking about and they they would
go on in loops mm-hmm so I'd be thinking
about just the most bizarre [ __ ] like
you know things that I I would never
think I thought about and wouldn't want
to admit to like my competitive side
like am i walking more miles than the
person I started with and like that that
was kind of early obsession like how
many miles am i doing
you know you get given a trail name
what's my trail name gonna be
and they all revolved early on in the
hike around like how strangers saw me
and I thought of myself as someone that
didn't give a [ __ ] about what other
people thought and I suddenly realized I
care
long about what people think and these
aren't people I know these are just
random people and I'm thinking about it
all day long
right why so I had to answer that
question kind of so that's how I kind of
proceeded on the hikers I would work out
what the hell I was thinking about
because it would just be driving me
bonkers and then I try and analyze why I
thought about it and so like I realized
that you know I spent a lot of time
thinking about expectations guilt and
disappointment and how expectations are
kind of the the parent of both guilt and
disappointment and I got to this place
where I realized you know society has
very strong expectations of us we have
expectations of ourselves and they're
generally unspoken and different from a
goal or an ambition they're the things
that we we don't check in again
regularly with ourselves and say am i
equipped to even meet this expectation
you know do I want to is this something
that I care about or is it just
something that the TV commercial thinks
I should care about and so you know I
realized that for me it sounds kind of
bizarre but like in order to get to my
true nature I could only do it in nature
and and nature is very very
non-judgmental but at the same time
brutal right it doesn't give a [ __ ]
about death nature does not care about
my whining doesn't care about where the
next water is it just is so as a partner
walking with nature yeah it was tough at
the beginning it really it kind of broke
me and I needed it frankly I don't know
if there's a similar for you but I just
I didn't I would never have admitted
this to myself but I needed to be broken
I needed to reach that breaking point
where I was just desperate and then I
needed to keep going because basically I
think my issue
psychologically neurotically was I was
afraid of being abandoned right
and what you realize by being in nature
is that you're gonna be okay I'm
completely by myself with nothing and
I'm fine I'm fine
and that teacher taught me that that was
kind of like a childhood yeah in
childhood you can be abandoned because
you need other people's help but now I'm
actually gonna be fine
so that that was like lesson number one
yeah that's profound I mean I think the
idea is almost like you're on this
four-month silent meditation retreat
right and and initially the looping you
know patterns of the thinking brain are
attacking you because you're so
acclimated to living however you were
living and ultimately creating some
awareness around that and becoming the
observer of that and engaging with it
you know on a subject specific matter to
get to a point where you then kind of
graduate to a greater awareness of your
pitfalls and your hang-ups etc to kind
of culminate in a more meta you know
perspective of what's important and
what's not it's beautiful it's like this
it's this sort of compacted hero's
journey yeah it didn't it felt like
survivor designed by by the young
Alfredo I didn't sign up for this rich
yeah but you did I do it's not leveling
unconsciously or not like this is what
you wanted right you were seeking this
like and on some level perhaps you
needed it you're at a crossroads in your
life and there was something beckoning
you to do this and you had to know that
that this was going to be part of the
deal right that you were gonna be
meeting your maker so to speak along the
way and that's part of the allure as
much as it is you know the fear that
surrounds doing something like that I
wish I could say that that was true but
for me I think I was so [ __ ]
oblivious to where I was at and so numb
and frankly just cynical that I don't
think I was self-aware enough to realize
what it was that I was engaged in and
somehow I did I think there was a deeper
level that must have known that yeah
there must have been a compulsion to at
least cultivate a
deeper level of self-awareness well I
knew I didn't feel comfortable in my own
skin I didn't feel comfortable being the
person I was in and I knew that I needed
to go through some kind of cathartic
process I thought it would be physical
so that that's kind of that's the part
that surprised me is that I thought you
know and I looked at everything I did
had these little matrix matrices that I
gauge different aspects of the walk
along just because you have nothing else
to do apart from make this [ __ ] up so
one of them one of them was around for
instance journey versus destination am I
thinking about getting to the next food
or may actually present right now
another was physical mental and I think
I thought it would be about 80% physical
20% mental and it was completely the
yeah it was definitely 80% mental and it
definitely tested me and I hadn't done
meditation before and the meditation
practice that I do now really is to get
me back to the peace and being present
that I felt on the heights right and
really it's like ready-made being
present like just just add nature and
you get presents because it is so
grounding you know just sleeping
outdoors every day seeing the stars
breathing the air I mean it gets back to
the earlier point of that's where we
come from we are part of nature nature
is part of us that was kind of the
Epiphany I had was really around if we
had a creation if we created a creation
myth it would be very different now than
theirs in the Bible's that we read and
it would be about actually facts and the
facts are you know 11 and a half billion
years ago there was an infinitesimally
dense atom that expanded and created
time and space and so Stardust is in
and we are in Stardust we are all part
of this same endeavor which is life and
the universe that's beautifully but I
like that so armed with that when you
return how do you then reframe your life
and figure out what the next chapter is
for you like what point what about that
experience then colored the decisions
that you've made about what you're going
to do next it was really really really
hard coming back much harder than the
acclimatization process of going from
civilization to nature came from nature
I'd be really fascinated I talked to
other people who've done these long
distance hikes and none of them have
really ever acclimatized back I've done
a lot of more hiking since because so if
you imagine the process is we we
experience the world through our five
senses that's it that is the reality we
call reality is only through our five
senses and in nature you are allowed to
open up your senses so the most shocking
one was smell because smell is so
beautiful and natural and harmonious in
it it's like a blanket you go from one
smell to another whereas in cities the
smell is really nasty and the same is
true of sound so here it's very quiet
but I live right in the middle of the
city and so so in nature I'd opened up
all my senses that was the progress I'd
made is to allow myself to be vulnerable
and open up the center the city required
me to shut it all down and I didn't want
to shut it down
and so I'd get headaches from the sirens
and the noise and the smell and its
really bright the lights at night it's
like a synesthesia yeah Wow so it was
really and I don't think I've still
recovered and I'm not sure I want to
fully recover it because living in a
manufactured we live in a manufacture
environment I don't want to be in a from
the hike I never want to rush again I
don't want to be in a rush like life is
here to savor and I don't want to be in
a place where I'm you know in in a
building where the air is piped in where
I'm looking at a screen all day I don't
want my relationship with this precious
life to be through a computer an object
so yeah it has taken me remarkably
longer than I ever would have imagined I
actually hired am I love life coaches
and I I hired a coach to help me when I
got back think about I want to do my job
now I want to do the next job and three
months into it her name was Mona she was
like charity have you ever thought about
the fact you might just not be ready I
was like yeah I'm not ready I'm
absolutely not ready so I said while
your wife's like alright so what are we
doing yeah what we're doing is spending
my 401k so I spent like yeah I know I've
spent it all I have like 75 grand left
in my 401k and it will all go I'm sure
and you know Oscar Wilde said that youth
is wasted on the young
well retirement is wasted on the old so
my retirement savings would be wasted on
the old totally yeah so for all of you
those those people who are out there
like how the [ __ ] you just can't do this
yeah you can yeah you can absolutely do
it you just there's some sacrifices and
trade-offs and I love getting those
checks from Prudential that way I didn't
even know I had this money now I can use
it yeah well what I love about that is
that you didn't technically experience
some kind of crazy you know life crisis
or even professional crisis like you
seem to have been fulfilled in what you
were what you were doing professionally
it's not like oh my god you know my life
is going down the tubes I need to like
hit pause now like it was you know you
were on a trajectory that that was that
was good that you were
enjoying and yet you still had the
awareness to recognize like I need to
take a break here and connect in a
different way in order to really
understand myself well enough to figure
out what the next you know a couple
decades are gonna look like
I was pretty lost I was fulfilled I
loved doing the work at EPA but at the
same time I mean how can we do these
jobs of protecting the environment that
we care and love with never being in the
environment that we care and love so I
felt really detached and unconnected
from this world that becomes an academic
enterprise despite the fact you were
this boots-on-the-ground guy like from
what I understand your predecessor
wasn't doing that kind of stuff like
showing up actually on all these out all
these sites yeah I mean I love I'm gonna
bring that emphasis and and I wanted to
meet the people I wanted to see the
places but even even that it yeah I
definitely felt the the cynicism part
and the calcification and the numbness
to life definitely felt very tangible
and and just being judgmental and it
felt very heavy like the biggest before
I left on the trail the biggest kind of
thing that I looked at was the the
difference between letting go and
holding on so with nearly anything that
you look at in life you could put it
through that lens and you know I think
how this whole I was like
white-knuckling it and holding on so
tight and even to the people that we
love I think we have this concept that
if we hold them they'll stay but really
what we do is suffocate them so I just I
came to a place where I was like I just
need to let go and just be happy
free-falling and actually I did jump out
of a plane it was terrifying but no but
literally just allow myself and that's
what the
Pacific Crest Trail did for me was just
allow me to get back to a place where I
was realizing this is who Jarrod is and
really the epiphany is this is my life
and I'm living it and a lot of times I
realize looking back I couldn't say yes
to both those things sometimes it didn't
feel like my life and I wasn't always
sure that I was living it so now that's
basically the mantra that I live by is
like this is my life
and I want to live it and you've been
able to hang on to that yes Sensibility
I'm never gonna let go of that's cool
that's cool and you've started a podcast
I have there's there's one thing that
you've done I've done a few yeah like
well you have this consulting practice
nice to write that yes so but that both
of those again were just kind of letting
the universe you know being receptive to
things that felt close to my heart
and you know so for instance the the
consulting thing with people that had so
for instance there's this guy who wants
to UM you can you can you'd like this
guy he um he wants to stop micro fibers
from like Patagonia and other kind of
fleeces he's come up with a device that
you could put in washing machines and it
basically like a lint trap for micro
fibers so cool idea and he wants me to
help him like how do we make this into a
statewide initiative so those are kind
of things that I love doing it's like or
how do you ban straws when people come
to me and say we'd like to pay you to do
that I'm like I'd love to do that that's
fun and the podcast came through my
cousin David just saying Jarrod no one's
really talking about environmental
issues and to a large extent everyone's
talking about environmental issues
because the world around us is is a big
sphere but like I like exploring these
issues and as you know I spent a huge
amount
time by myself and so for me getting to
to talk to people and be in conversation
and experience their wisdom is a gift I
love doing it so yeah when someone says
you could actually do this like hanging
out talking with you I there's nothing
I'd rather be doing this is so cool yeah
to do it it's cool and we were talking
before the before the we hit record you
know I don't know that anybody yeah we
all kind of generally talk about the
environment but there's nobody with your
experience and pedigree who's doing you
know an actual podcast around these
ideas and and these are ideas that can
be spoken about both broadly and very
specifically and you're in a you know
the perfect you're sort of the perfect
cipher for those kinds of conversations
so I think it's cool it's called pod
ship earth pass shipper and so pod ship
earth came from buckminster fuller's
book operating manual for spaceship and
I had this wacky great-uncle called
Milton who late in life you know he was
a jock he was not a reader I'm not sure
what happened but like in his mid 80s he
discovered Buckminster Fuller and he
unlike me he didn't do the Pacific Crest
Trail but he turned his savings in as a
meager as they were and bought hundreds
of copies of Bucky's book called
critical path and we're gonna say he
bought a dome I do you know
unfortunately he kind of ended up in
really seedy motels
in in Miami Beach but no he should have
different stories he should have bought
a dome he would have been much much
happier in a geodesic dome but he did
buy hundreds of copies of the book and
he handed me one is and I end my memory
at a time was like what the [ __ ] he used
to give me a hundred dollar bills for
Christmas and now I'm getting a critical
path by Buckminster Fuller but I
eventually got around to reading it and
had a big impact on kind of systems
thinking and like podge spaceship earth
paja / yeah there we are we are this
teeny little dot my kids I'd invite
every
every single listener to look up there's
a YouTube video of this guy talking
about the Virgo supercluster which our
galaxy is in and when you see the scale
of the galaxy that we're in and then
this Virgo supercluster we are a teeny
little spaceship this is that one that
that starts with the earth and then
slowly progressively zooms out yes I'll
put a link in the show notes you know it
is pretty cool that's cool that's
awesome man so the first episode drops
late February February 19th it's gonna
have Gina McCarthy she was my boss at
EPA she was a head of EPA she's now at
the Kennedy School she's she's been our
whole life a fighter she was
ridiculously optimistic about our
prospects of turning this around which I
liked I'm looking for optimism that's
cool good all right well we gotta wrap
this up but I don't want to let you go
without two remaining questions the
first is if people are listening and
they're inspired to get more
environmentally conscious and active in
their own lives like what are some of
the the most impactful things that the
average consumer can put into motion the
most important thing is yourself and
your family um that's the most important
unit we have and then your community but
within your family little things like
you know being consumer minded
environmentally minded when it comes to
choices I was helping my son by a pillow
the other day you don't want a pillow
with brominated flame retardants you
want a pillow that's made out of organic
things you're putting your head on it
when it comes to you know getting
chocolate if it has Fairtrade why not
get the Fairtrade one you know that it's
coming from a place where there's not
slave labour using the chocolate when it
comes to making a decision about buying
a case of plastic bottles for your kids
soccer game or you know maybe buying
five or six stainless steel bottles that
can be refilled you know make the smart
choice those things will last forever
even just you know kids birthday parties
or your own birthday parties those
styrofoam plates people it's so much
classier and nicer to use actual
ceramics and cutlery people love it so
like enjoy life but be conscious that
you can really make some pretty profound
choices you could put solar on your roof
you can decide you know what I am NOT
gonna go to the gym I don't have the
money but I live five miles away from
where I work I'm gonna walk every day
you will be amazed
I walked every day and I it was so
eye-opening I got to know people on the
street I got a lot fitter and I didn't
have to be cooped up in a car which you
know the air is bad you get stressed so
if she choose a life that is simple and
honest to your values and and that
really just means looking after your
health and your health of your family
the next thing is your community things
like tree plantings community gardens
the whole focus on public policy and the
things that really I don't think matter
quite as much as the individual action
at the local level so I would say act
locally resist nationally mm-hmm I like
that but on the subject of policy and
this leads me to my final question if
you did find yourself in some parallel
universe where you had been appointed to
run the EPA and you're in Washington in
your nice office what do you do first
what is the what is the policy agenda
look like if you are in charge so we we
kind of know what the policies need to
be in order to get out of the mess that
we're in they need to be driven by
science
so with climate change there's already a
finding that greenhouse gases are a
pollutant it's called the endangerment
finding that can't be changed because
the science hasn't changed so really let
science be our guide and then secondly
the laws are pretty clear that we need
to protect human health and the
environment let's do that so with
climate change we had a common-sense
plan called the clean power plan
that was in place we got four and a half
million public comments now they're
saying there probably wasn't enough
public comment I mean so yeah there's a
lot of public comment it was a great
plan the energy companies bought into it
and realized they needed certainty so
moving very quickly to renewable energy
and in some cases I think the state of
California can have a goal of a hundred
percent renewable energy cities need to
move in that direction so energy is move
as fast and now it's you know from a
fiscal perspective we have an obligation
to do it because it's cheaper with water
there's a huge amount of savings we're
going to get into another drought in the
West no doubt soon we need to think
about the whole system of turning waste
water into water that can be used for
other purposes from irrigation to
washing our laundry so water is really
important chemicals there's 80,000
chemicals in place that have no
regulation whatsoever we need to
drastically reduce the number of
chemicals that are allowed into our
environment until we know what the hell
it is they're gonna do we need to make
sure that communities of color and
low-income communities aren't left
behind that they aren't the you know
bearing the brunt of the pollution that
makes our lives easier and you know we
need as quick and acceleration towards
policies like organic agriculture you
know the subsidies have been helping
large-scale commercial petrochemical AG
for a long time so we need to get
government's money with you and I pay
all of us pay we pay taxes those taxes
need to go towards doing the right thing
as opposed to continually paying for the
polluters yeah if we could shift some of
the focus away from farm bill type
legislation towards incentivizing the
organic farming community and the local
farming communities
would be a step in the right direction I
have a question for you yeah so I had a
difficult time readjusting you're
sleeping in a tent yeah
so I'm jealous like tell me you can
sleep in a tent I could it's hard in
teheran TISCO we're backyard no I was
thinking the roof roof yeah yeah so well
my tent was on the flat roof but the
wind was crazy lately so I've moved it
down to current to ground level but yeah
I've been sleeping in a roof in in a
tent for about a year and a half before
that kind of periodically on and off and
I love it
you know I love it it's a it was
motivated initially by struggles with
sleep that I was having and I like it
cold like the colder the better you know
get under a bunch of blankets and I just
sleep phenomenally well and my wife
likes it warm and so we would argue
people are like is your marriage okay
but it's like it's actually better now
because she gets it the way she likes it
and I get it the way I like it and I
can't do anything if I don't sleep well
and so a my sleep quality improved like
tenfold like I don't know how you were
sleeping on the trail but hmm just being
laughing there yeah it's amazing a good
I love it for that alone but I also
think it it speaks to you know I have it
right adjacent to this container space
out there that I have my office and like
my little world is like that tent in
that container and I happen to live in a
beautiful home and I'm extremely
grateful and lucky and you know I have
my life is an embarrassment of riches
but on some level it's sort of a it's a
it's a practice in in stoicism because
if everything went to [ __ ] and I lost
everything like I'm cool like I yeah
it's reframed my relationship with the
material world in a way that allows me
to really embrace and understand like I
don't need that much like and my
happiness and sense of self is not
dictated by those externalities and it's
it's and and then there was a what you
know I was doing it for a while and then
I I wasn't saying anything publicly
about I'm like what would people think
they're gonna think I'm and then I'm
like I don't care yeah you know I don't
care whatever you thought it there but
you know I like it and and
it's been a cool thing so put that town
on your roof I like it
I'm just final point I have never been
happier than when I was on the Pacific
Crest Trail and I had everything that I
needed in my bangbang right yeah so
happiness is not a function of the
material possessions that you lug around
with you it's more a function of the
experience that you choose to bring into
your life and the people that you
surround yourself with and your
relationship to that environment and
those people well thank you so much for
inviting me today thank you it was a
pleasure good luck with the podcast well
I'm gonna invite you I need you as a
guest happy to come I don't know what I
could say on the environmental issues
but anytime you want to have me now
you've I want to hear all about your
lawyer Inge and how you made the
transformation and what you felt like
when you did your fifth Ironman in five
days and like this is a promo for the
show you're gonna you've already heard
it because he's talked about it on this
show yeah cool man all right well
awesome so if people want to connect
with you or hook up with you which
where's the best place for them to do
that I'm pod ship earth comm yeah all
right the new website awesome and
subscribe on iTunes check it out all
that kind of stuff alright Jared thank
you rich peace yeah
[Music]
you